Seção 10 de Dom Casmurro.
Esta é uma gravação LibriVox. Todas as gravações LibriVox estão em domínio público. Para mais informações, ou para ser um voluntário, por favor visite: librivox.org.
Gravado por Rachel Moraes.
Dom Casmurro, de Joaquim Maria Machado de Assis.
Capítulos XLVI a L.
Capítulo XLVI As Pazes
As pazes fizeram-se como a guerra, depressa. Buscasse eu neste livro a minha glória, e diria que as negociações partiram de mim; mas não, foi ela que as iniciou. Alguns instantes depois, como eu estivesse cabisbaixo, ela abaixou também a cabeça, mas voltando os olhos para cima a fim de ver os meus. Fiz-me de rogado; depois quis levantar-me para ir embora, mas nem me levantei, nem sei se iria.
Capitu fitou-me uns olhos tão ternos, e a posição os fazia tão súplices, que me deixei ficar, passei-lhe o braço pela cintura, ela pegou-me na ponta dos dedos, e...
Outra vez D. Fortunata apareceu à porta da casa; não sei para que, se nem me deixou tempo de puxar o braço; desapareceu logo. Podia ser um simples descargo de consciência, uma cerimônia, como as rezas de obrigação, sem devoção, que se dizem de tropel; a não ser que fosse para certificar aos próprios olhos a realidade que o coração lhe dizia...
Fosse o que fosse, o meu braço continuou a apertar a cintura da filha, e foi assim que nos pacificamos. O bonito é que cada um de nós queria agora as culpas para si, e pedíamos reciprocamente perdão. Capitu alegava a insônia, a dor de cabeça, o abatimento do espírito, e finalmente os seus calundus. Eu, que era muito chorão por esse tempo, sentia os olhos molhados... Era amor puro, era efeito dos padecimentos da amiguinha, era a ternura da reconciliação.
Capítulo XLVII “A Senhora Saiu”
— Está bom, acabou, disse eu finalmente; mas, explique-me só uma coisa, por que é que você me perguntou se eu tinha medo de apanhar?
— Não foi por nada, respondeu Capitu, depois de alguma hesitação... Para que bulir nisso?
— Diga sempre. Foi por causa do seminário?
— Foi; ouvi dizer que lá dão pancada... Não? Eu também não creio.
A explicação agradou-me; não tinha outra. Se, como penso, Capitu não disse a verdade, força é reconhecer que não podia dizê-la, e a mentira é dessas criadas que se dão pressa em responder às visitas que “a senhora saiu”, quando a senhora não quer falar a ninguém. Há nessa cumplicidade um gosto particular; o pecado em comum iguala por instantes a condição das pessoas, não contando o prazer que dá a cara das visitas enganadas, e as costas com que elas descem...
A verdade não saiu, ficou em casa, no coração de Capitu, cochilando o seu arrependimento. E eu não desci triste nem zangado; achei a criada galante, apetecível, melhor que a ama.
As andorinhas vinham agora em sentido contrário, ou não seriam as mesmas. Nós é que éramos os mesmos; ali ficamos, somando as nossas ilusões, os nossos temores, começando já a somar as nossas saudades.
Capítulo XLVIII Juramento do Poço
— Não! exclamei de repente.
— Não quê?
Tinha havido alguns minutos de silêncio, durante os quais refleti muito e acabei por uma ideia; o tom da exclamação, porém, foi tão alto que espantou a minha vizinha.
— Não há de ser assim, continuei. Dizem que não estamos em idade de casar, que somos crianças, criançolas, — já ouvi dizer criançolas. Bem; mas dois ou três anos passam depressa. Você jura uma coisa? Jura que só há de casar comigo?
Capitu não hesitou em jurar, e até lhe vi as faces vermelhas de prazer. Jurou duas vezes e uma terceira:
— Ainda que você case com outra, cumprirei o meu juramento, não casando nunca.
— Que eu case com outra?
— Tudo pode ser, Bentinho. Você pode achar outra moça que lhe queira, apaixonar-se por ela e casar. Quem sou eu para você lembrar-se de mim nessa ocasião?
— Mas eu também juro! Juro, Capitu, juro por Deus Nosso Senhor que só me casarei com você. Basta isto?
— Devia bastar, disse ela; eu não me atrevo a pedir mais. Sim, você jura... Mas juremos por outro modo; juremos que nos havemos de casar um com outro, haja o que houver.
Compreendeis a diferença; era mais que a eleição do cônjuge, era a afirmação do matrimônio. A cabeça da minha amiga sabia pensar claro e depressa. Realmente, a fórmula anterior era limitada, apenas exclusiva. Podíamos acabar solteirões, como o sol e a lua, sem mentir ao juramento do poço. Esta fórmula era melhor, e tinha a vantagem de me fortalecer o coração contra a investidura eclesiástica. Juramos pela segunda fórmula, e ficamos tão felizes que todo receio de perigo desapareceu.
Éramos religiosos, tínhamos o céu por testemunha. Eu nem já temia o seminário.
— Se teimarem muito, irei; mas faço de conta que é um colégio qualquer; não tomo ordens.
Capitu temia a nossa separação, mas acabou aceitando este alvitre, que era o melhor. Não afligíamos minha mãe, e o tempo correria até o ponto em que o casamento pudesse fazer-se. Ao contrário, qualquer resistência ao seminário confirmaria a denúncia de José Dias. Esta reflexão não foi minha, mas dela.
Capítulo XLIX Uma Vela aos Sábados
Eis aqui como, após tantas canseiras, tocávamos o porto a que nos devíamos ter abrigado logo. Não nos censures, piloto de má morte, não se navegam corações como os outros mares deste mundo. Estávamos contentes, entramos a falar do futuro. Eu prometia à minha esposa uma vida sossegada e bela, na roça ou fora da cidade. Viríamos aqui uma vez por ano. Se fosse em arrabalde, seria longe, onde ninguém nos fosse aborrecer.
A casa, na minha opinião, não devia ser grande nem pequena, um meio-termo; plantei-lhe flores, escolhi móveis, uma sege e um oratório. Sim, havíamos de ter um oratório bonito, alto, de jacarandá, com a imagem de Nossa Senhora da Conceição.
Demorei-me mais nisto que no resto, em parte porque éramos religiosos, em parte para compensar a batina que eu ia deitar às urtigas; mas ainda restava uma parte que atribuo ao intuito secreto e inconsciente de captar a proteção do céu. Havíamos de acender uma vela aos sábados...
Capítulo L Um Meio-Termo
Meses depois fui para o seminário de São José. Se eu pudesse contar as lágrimas que chorei na véspera e na manhã, somaria mais que todas as vertidas desde Adão e Eva. Há nisto alguma exageração; mas é bom ser enfático, uma ou outra vez, para compensar este escrúpulo de exatidão que me aflige. Entretanto, se eu me ativer só à lembrança da sensação, não fico longe da verdade; aos quinze anos, tudo é infinito.
Realmente, por mais preparado que estivesse, padecia muito. Minha mãe também padeceu, mas sofria com alma e coração; demais, o Padre Cabral achara um meio-termo: experimentar-me a vocação; se no fim de dois anos, eu não revelasse vocação eclesiástica, seguiria outra carreira.
— As promessas devem ser cumpridas conforme Deus quer. Suponha que Nosso Senhor nega disposição a seu filho, e que o costume do seminário não lhe dá o gosto que me concedeu a mim, é que a vontade divina é outra. A senhora não podia pôr em seu filho, antes de nascido, uma vocação que Nosso Senhor lhe recusou...
Era uma concessão do padre. Dava a minha mãe um perdão antecipado, fazendo vir do credor a relevação da dívida. Os olhos dela brilharam, mas a boca disse que não. José Dias, não tendo alcançado ir comigo para a Europa, agarrou-se ao mais próximo, e apoiou o “alvitre do Sr. protonotário”; só lhe parecia que um ano era bastante.
— Estou certo, disse ele, piscando-me o olho, que dentro de um ano a vocação eclesiástica do nosso Bentinho se manifesta clara e decisiva. Há de dar um padre de mão-cheia. Também, se não vier em um ano...
E a mim, mais tarde, em particular:
— Vá por um ano; um ano passa depressa. Se não sentir gosto nenhum, é que Deus não quer, como diz o padre, e nesse caso, meu amiguinho, o melhor remédio é a Europa.
Capitu deu-me igual conselho, quando minha mãe lhe anunciou a minha ida definitiva para o seminário:
— Minha filha, você vai perder o seu companheiro de criança...
Fez-lhe tão bem este tratamento de filha — era a primeira vez que minha mãe lho dava —, que nem teve tempo de ficar triste; beijou-lhe a mão, e disse-lhe que já sabia disso por mim mesmo. Em particular animou-me a suportar tudo com paciência; no fim de um ano as coisas estariam mudadas, e um ano andava depressa. Não foi ainda a nossa despedida; esta fez-se na véspera, por um modo que pede capítulo especial.
O que unicamente digo aqui é que, ao passo que nos prendíamos um ao outro, ela ia prendendo minha mãe, fez-se mais assídua e terna, vivia ao pé dela, com os olhos nela. Minha mãe era de natural simpático, e igualmente sensível; tanto se doía como se aprazia de qualquer coisa. Entrou a achar em Capitu uma porção de graças novas, de dotes finos e raros; deu-lhe um anel dos seus e algumas galanterias.
Não consentiu em fotografar-se, como a pequena lhe pedia, para lhe dar um retrato; mas tinha uma miniatura, feita aos vinte e cinco anos, e, depois de algumas hesitações, resolveu dar-lha. Os olhos de Capitu, quando recebeu o mimo, não se descrevem; não eram oblíquos, nem de ressaca, eram direitos, claros, lúcidos. Beijou o retrato com paixão, minha mãe fez-lhe a mesma coisa a ela. Tudo isto me lembra a nossa despedida.
Fim da seção 10.
Gravado por Rachel Moraes.